[Music]
[Laughter]
this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app that's
before we even start let's go over some
of these [ __ ] cities I'm coming too
we added some late shows in these cities
and tickets are still available because
the first one sold out immediately
babies Des Moines who knew Des Moines
they have got two S's one at the end of
each word and you don't pronounce either
get rid of them both naturally get rid
of them both but Des Moines I will be
there in a little bit
Edmonton I will be there Late Show
tickets are still on sale Victoria BC
Late Show tickets are still on sale
Chicago tickets are still on sale for
the Late Show or sorry for the second or
third show I don't know whatever but
this is episode 116 and my babies our
podcast is Soren it is Soren we're doing
well a lot of you guys are spreading
this cult and spreading the word it's
free conch
you can listen to any podcast but a lot
of you guys are just tried and true with
us man and helping us get that wood for
that log cabin man because this is a
cult
dude I see what these guys are trying to
do I see what the [ __ ] in half a minute
to Mars guys are trying to do and do it
they're trying to make a cult but they
do not have a cult dude their coat looks
like it sucks do it it looks too serious
it looks way too serious that's the
thing about cults they're too [ __ ]
serious dude
our [ __ ] is silly goose time a lot of
these cults were talking about the end
of the world a lot of these cults are
talking about the the days come in the
[ __ ] resurrection and all this
[ __ ] [ __ ] and sucking [ __ ] and
sucking and tallgrass dude it's
uncomfortable [ __ ] and sucking and
tallgrass he's like oh yeah but oh yeah
now that's what's up dude on a raised
log cabin off the tall grass we're live
on my app if you want to see the podcast
before anybody else sees it you go to
the you go to the App Store and you dial
in crystally and you download it dude
guess what you know you know I never
thought I'd go to war with a city I
never thought I'd go to war with the
city but I'm at war with a city baby I
talked about Albuquerque on [ __ ]
Twitter and they [ __ ] and then I and
guess what now they endued they're back
social media shedding more light on his
comments Christie Leo performed earlier
another segment dude another segment
another segment two segments two
segments too many I'm a correspondent at
this point dude they came back and did
another segment last episode I talked
about Albuquerque and they did a segment
on me about how I caught on called bash
them and this [ __ ] after why the way
they they said my name right in the
first one shade they didn't say oh right
in the second one you know what it is
social media shedding more light on his
comments Chris D'Elia performed earlier
this month at the Kimo theater
afterwards he took to Twitter saying
quote I've been to some blank holes but
holy blank you make Jacksonville look
like paradise you already know this many
New Mexicans criticized him on social
media well a couple days after our story
aired Tilly responded to the outcry
Celia couldn't believe the response
I was there for eight hours and my
podcast on their [ __ ] news segment
Weiss I'm sure it's fine something like
that
now he still hasn't revealed an exact
reason for not liking Albuquerque but he
did poke fun at Kimo theater snake does
the best part and said our buildings are
short Turkey but he did poke fun at Kimo
theatres name and said our buildings are
short dude the newscaster said that
[Music]
dude the newscaster said I said that the
buildings are short I said you had to
crouch down into him dude what the [ __ ]
man
hey bed by the way there was another
child shot by the way there was a murder
they murdered 70 people in Albuquerque
unbelievable dude prop Albuquerque's
turned out to be my favorite [ __ ]
city in the u.s. dude just because of
their [ __ ] they clap back they have a
clap back effect I told my buddy about
this and he was saying that you know cuz
Aaron Paul shot Aaron's a buddy of mine
from Breaking Bad and that Aaron Paul
shot
they shot Breaking Bad Breaking Bad over
in Albuquerque and the reason why you
know that is because any time you step
foot in Albuquerque
everything about Breaking Bad is
plastered all over so he said something
about Albuquerque that wasn't favorable
one time and they made a whole segment
about him so I made me feel less special
so that's that's okay that's okay that's
okay
but they make it a big [ __ ] deal
about it and that's hilarious to me dude
so Albuquerque shoutout to you dude
you're becoming my favorite city in the
u.s. just because of the segments men ha
ha this just in about Albuquerque
[ __ ] James Woods is shooting a movie
here and he just said it was too cold we
check in to some locals here to see
about how they feel about James Woods
saying that it's too cold I don't know I
mean you know it's just it's it's it
depends really what what when you come
the seasons are different and obviously
it's going to be colder in January and
February than it is going to be in July
you know maybe if you came in the summer
it would have been it would have been
warmer but you know if he's gonna come
during the winter obviously it's gonna
be colder so I don't know maybe they
should shoot movies in the summer
James Woods was not available for
comment but he's took to Twitter bashing
liberals so yeah dude anyway I'm you
know loving it I don't know whatever
they mispronounced my name on the second
segment but on the first segment they
got it right hey hey Albuquerque
so whatever dude this this is my dis you
got a/c bro something I never thought of
in my life was and I saw an instant I
saw in I don't know it was an Instagram
or YouTube video of this this blew my
mind this I haven't laughed this hard in
I would say years okay thinking about
the seeing this first of all if you're
in the video podcast you can see this
but you imagine it because I never
thought about this you know those
[ __ ] signs that they twirl around
with the arrow it's like [ __ ] you
know Bojangles chicken or like KFC it's
usually a chicken place for some reason
I don't know why
or like RadioShack and they got sign
throwers that are just [ __ ] there
this [ __ ] they're just twirling them
around because they're so goddamn bored
just standing out there like I'm not a
post I used to have a bit about that
actually on stage I don't know if I put
it in a special or not but if you're a
sign holder or like you know if you can
be replaced with tape you know of course
there's a movido YouTube video
amazing amazing professional sign
spinner of course the guy is called dr.
spin you know but there's a [ __ ] in I
want to keep that later there's a
youtube video I think it was a vine
originally but about this sign thrower I
never thought about how if they're
constantly spinning the [ __ ] signs you
don't know where the place is
you know what I'm talking about like
they got the arrow that shows the place
so there's this video
online that it said and this girl is
just yeah I haven't laughed this hard
just think about the goat so the guys
spinning the Quiznos sign and it's going
[ __ ] nuts
alright and this is what he's spinning
it around and she wants to go to Quiznos
[Laughter]
dude when I first saw that I cried I
cried I couldn't catch my breath dude I
haven't laughed that hard you know what
that to me that's seven seconds six
seconds
distilled is the funniest six seconds I
could imagine all right you know let me
just let me break it down to why I think
that this [ __ ] is so funny okay first of
all the guys spinning the sign around
the guy for anytime a guy thinks he's
the [ __ ] [ __ ] we're at a [ __ ] Mach
10 on funniness okay it doesn't matter
if the guy is this [ __ ] or he's not this
[ __ ] but it's like when George Brett was
like I [ __ ] my pants last night he was s
some baseball thinks he's the [ __ ] you
know if a guy's wearing a long trench
coat and walks into like a [ __ ] cool
place and you could tell he's fooling
himself I laugh hard any time someone
sings things to the [ __ ] it's goddamn
hilarious okay so this guy is killing
the sign I mean just twirling it around
like it's magic okay so already I think
it's funny it's funny that that's even a
job also
alright and then this girl just wants to
eat like she just wants to eat dude and
she's frustrated that's another thing
that makes me laugh so hard when
someone's frustrated so you've got
someone who thinks through the [ __ ] and
then someone who's just frustrated and
hungry dude
don't even know which way the Quiznos oh
dude
that's that I laughed I mean I was
crying dude six seconds I don't even
know what you're the Quiznos is I don't
even know it or the quiz like some she's
probably some you could tell to its in
Canada actually because the [ __ ] walk
the walking sign in the background in
Canada they have the [ __ ] chillest
walk walk signals in America it's a guy
like this let that's like when it says
you can cross the crosswalk and then in
Canada it's a guy like this he's a
little bit tipped back like he's
chilling like he's an old black guy in
the 70s that's just like hey Blair like
that's how the they're different
I saw they're a little different I don't
know why but it's more chill out it's
cuz it's cuz weed has been legal in
Canada for a while probably maybe so
anyway yeah but dude that [ __ ] made me
made me laugh so hard I got a I got a
what do you call it
dude videos or this guy the Internet is
just sometimes the Internet is just so
great sometimes the internet just
[ __ ] like like is just so shitty
you know because of how because of how
how like like Whitney tweeted something
the other day that was like about the
Cathedral the Notre Dame that was has
been burned obviously terrible and
Whitney just tweeted at a joke that's
like you know you can you can see how
how people are what do you call it
people have turned into the turn the
tragedy into turn the tragedy into
bragging about their vacation in Paris
and people of course went nuts over it
but she's like dude I can't believe I
had to say this but like obviously now
I'm not talking about everybody outta
yada but like dude [ __ ] calm down the
outrage is crazy but but sometimes the
internet on the other end
is is this this guy this tweet this guy
mister plenty at of wooed on on Twitter
dude this [ __ ] kill me this thread is so
funny to me I tweeted it never seen Star
Wars
none of them never will oh my god you're
missing out maybe you're missing out on
being a multimillionaire keep your movie
and then it's picture of him in front of
a Bentley at the dealership by the way
maybe didn't even buy it so somebody
then he writes a follow up thing not
your car not your car it has my last
name Tate t8 on the number plate too
much Star Wars makes you dumb and then
it shows him driving around in his
Bentley okay guys I have more than you
again guys have more cars that I stand
next to if you want to learn how to make
money online in between watching dork
Wars go to his website Dora Korres
didn't even try just such a troll
everyone who's ever watched Star Wars in
human history is absolutely dirt poor no
exceptions only I can save you I teach
you how to make money online here and
then shows a picture of him standing
next to chicks and on a boat even
watching star a Star Wars trailer may
leave you homeless on the street with
AIDS only I have the path to absolute
financial freedom do not follow the Jedi
follow the Jesus learn how to get
unlimited girls and make unlimited money
here in the biz picture of his face on
Jesus cysec religious gone to hell I'm
and then women hate you they hate you
because you've watched Star Wars I can
correct how's a girl ever tattooed a
name on her name on you know it's cuz
you watch Star Wars lucky I teach you
the secrets of the female mind not only
how to get them but how to make them do
anything you say change your life today
do you have cool pictures of you with
cigars with piles of money on tropical
islands no you spend too much time
watching dork Wars luckily you can join
my war room and supercharge online money
making today I can convert I'm richer
than anyone who's ever seen Star Wars
ever like obviously this guy's just
[ __ ] around you know even the
inventor of Star Wars is a
penny-pinching little [ __ ] compared to
the awesome nearing incalculable power
of my back
luckily I will teach you to do the same
I turned to her and said baby I've never
watched Star Wars and it's a picture of
him taking a [ __ ] firecracker thing
lighting a [ __ ] cigar dude anybody
that smokes a cigar is like you got you
dude you think you think you're the
[ __ ] dawn you know anybody thinks
that they're any let me let me put it to
you this way anybody who smokes a guitar
a guitar a cigar did do have a tumor
anyone who smokes a cigar first off you
smoke a guitar you're [ __ ] you're
awesome
if you smoke a cigar immediately I hate
your whole race you understand what I'm
saying if you're a white guy that smokes
a cigar I'm like these [ __ ] [ __ ]
white guys these fat [ __ ] white guys
that just [ __ ] sit around and smoke
cigars if you're a Mexican guy I'm like
all right dude I get it you know you're
chilling and [ __ ] some Mexican ass
place you're just like you think you're
[ __ ] you know Scarface or whatever
the [ __ ] cerise it's not even the right
but you know you know what I'm saying
I become racist if you're smoking a
cigar is what I'm saying I don't care if
you're white or whatever look at this
you can't argue with the results he
writes I think you're the most discussed
and then there's a text exchange I think
you're the most disgusting man I've ever
met I'd never date a guy like you you're
arrogant rude and you write horrible
things on the internet I've seen your
website you think you know how to get
girls you'll never get me and then he
writes I've never seen Star Wars and she
writes oh my god I'm sorry please give
me forgive me kind of suck your dick
rolling with this dude ah
and then I tweeted about this I said
this thread is [ __ ] hilarious
and then he DM me and said have you seen
Star Wars that's amazing and but some
people are like oh dude I guess this
fight guy fights in the in the UFC or
uwc I don't know what that is but yeah I
mean I guess this guy is just like my I
mean look at this one my penis is
heinous large veiny imagine describing
your penis is heinous first not just not
large at first Hey Dude what's your dick
like heinous dude it's heinous
it's [ __ ] heinous
who you [ __ ] Bill and Ted yeah dude I
I think that here's that's that covers a
lot of bases why I think it's funny too
cuz he's making fun of both sides that's
that kind of [ __ ] I love because he's
making fun of people who take Star Wars
too seriously he's making fun of them as
the character that's like this alpha bro
type which is like he's obviously saying
like he's making fun of that guy too
because he's being a piece-of-shit
cartoon version of that like he's making
fun of the bros and the Star Wars dorks
I don't know man look do what you want
man you know I talked about like don't
do this don't do that and people say
like sometimes like oh man you're so
judged
- like dude I'm really not like I more
than me wanting like like [ __ ] Coachella
you know like Coachella is going on
today - this week and everyone's
pretending that they want to go you know
and that's some Kuta [ __ ] obviously
super CUDA put capes on you goddamn
Barracuda bring a [ __ ] tank of water
and just swim around in it with a cape
on you [ __ ] super CUDA
but remember Leos picture at [ __ ]
Coachella where he's running around a
super soaker like a [ __ ] couldn't
have been more submit the photo when
he's like this if you're running and
your arms are behind you at all you're a
[ __ ] keep those arms [ __ ] in front
of you do it keep it [ __ ] Jackie
joyner-kersee style the second you move
your arms behind you when you're running
straight up [ __ ] straight-up [ __ ] them
put your arms in front bro be ready for
some [ __ ] dude check it out still a man
still a man still a man moving the arms
back still a man still a man still a man
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and you're making this noise you know
nothing more [ __ ] than hyperextending
your leg in a [ __ ] when you're
walking one time when I was in
elementary school I was walking down the
street and I was I was I think I was in
fifth grade or something like that in
New Jersey and I was walking down going
home and I was with some chicks that I
liked and I was with some dudes that
were Bros and I was walking down and I
was like man how come these girls
probably like these other guys better
than me I didn't know I don't know how
to make them like me and I felt very
confused because I was like coming of
age and I didn't know how to make the
girls like me and and and as I was
walking down I stepped in a hole a
little bit and a hyper-extended my knee
and I looked like such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
because I was walking ahead of them
because I didn't want to be embarrassed
while I was talking with them and I
[ __ ] high person on my leg and they
[ __ ] I thought they saw me so I just
literally started [ __ ] tearing up so
[ __ ] I started tearing up because I was
like already feeling low about myself
because the girls probably like the
other guys better bother I made it this
whole [ __ ] thing up in my head there
was
all made up in my head and ice
hyperextend on my knee and I and it hurt
and I started like crying a little bit
and then and then one of the girls
walked out to me and she's like hey are
you okay cuz like I was crying a little
bit and she didn't see me hyper except
my knee and I realized that she didn't
see me hi bricks on my knee so I was
like I'm not gonna tell her that I just
stepped in a ditch and started crying
because I thought that these girls
didn't like me and I was walking ahead
of him of them so instead I [ __ ] told
her my grandma died and they were both
alive I mean dude what a young sociopath
I [ __ ] stepped in a ditch teared up
in fifth grade and a girl was like hey
are you okay and I said yeah she said
what's wrong I said my grandma died cuz
I stepped in a ditch talk about
bitch-made dude I'm a Barbie I've got
pink hair coming out of my ass cuz I'm a
low pony oh my god do I fit in do I fit
in the front part of your jeans cuz I'm
a Polly Pocket dude what a [ __ ]
hyperextend all of it was [ __ ] dude I
was walking ahead of the girls because I
didn't because I was like you know what
lost cause they probably like the other
guys better I remember that there with
my other buddy Matt ravenna and who was
like a stud I always thought he was like
a stud I still know him he's one of my
best friends and and he [ __ ] and I
was like they probably liked him better
walking ahead stepped in a ditch started
crying the girls who were being sweet
what's wrong I said my grandma died my
grandma and I remember thinking like
great now I got a [ __ ] wait till my
grandma really dies I hope they don't
find out thank God there wasn't Google
they could have googled CaRMS II found
out she was alive dude I know grandma
Carmela
set Italian man my grandma Carmela was
so [ __ ] funny holy [ __ ] [ __ ] she
would eat cherry pie in the morning and
just not give a [ __ ] dude that's so dope
- where where to eat cherry pie in the
morning dude bro this is her eating
cherry pie in the morning just that's so
dope oh my god no it's this dude she
would show up and my dad would be like
every time she would she would come out
and stay with us me and my family for
like [ __ ] two weeks at a time it was
so long anyway every time she came she
was smaller and smaller grammars got
smallest [ __ ] dude
grandma's gets smallest [ __ ] if your
grandma lived to be over a hundred she's
a size of [ __ ] what do you call it we
men and and and one time she got her
hair cut and she was like 70 something
like 75 or 76 and she came over and she
said I think it makes me look younger
and we [ __ ] laughed so hard like how
much younger you're 75 you cut an inch
off your hair what do you look 73
goddamn she was so cute
Carm z Carmela dude she would make
meatballs her meatballs were the [ __ ]
dude and I know everyone says their
grandma's meatballs with this [ __ ] but
[ __ ] you dude these meatballs they're so
good and she would make the gravy she
would call it it's Italian to call sauce
gravy and she would eat cherry pie in
the morning and every time she would
show up my dad every single good morning
she would be like he would be like all
right well it was nice seeing ya and do
the dad joke were like she was leaving
but one time she was like at that
old-school racist to wear it you you
couldn't even like be mad cuz it was
just like she was born in [ __ ] 1412
she would just be like wow you know
they're different you know like Jesus
Christ and and so one time my two
friends were over and and they were and
she was like talking to him and and she
was talking about Jewish people and one
of my friends was Jewish and she was
like oh you don't look Jewish
and then she was and we were like look
Jewish what does look Jewish look like
they say oh you know you got like the
big noses and you were like ah I can't
say that and then she was like like him
and pointed at a [ __ ] my other friend
who by the way wasn't Jewish
[Laughter]
Karm see Jesus Christ um it's [ __ ]
weird how uh but uh if she was famous
everyone would have canceled her for
that if that gift there was video of
that she'd be like no don't eat her
meatballs don't eat her meatballs don't
eat her gravy take the gravy away from
her she's cancelled carbs he's cancelled
one time - she she she was taken off my
cousin's diaper when he was really young
and and he wouldn't it wouldn't like he
wasn't moving he was like no take it's
like now my cousin what he was just like
no mom ow
just didn't take the diaper off and then
she finally got it off and then she
wanted to put another diaper on he was
like wow and she said oh you're full of
[ __ ] and he said [ __ ] and ran out of
the room and just started saying
[ __ ]
full of [ __ ] Tom she taught him full of
[ __ ] dude we laughed we laughed do it
life's good man I'm back for ten [ __ ]
days in LA and life is good life is
[ __ ] good man you ever feel like life
is just good dude it might be raining it
might be [ __ ] snowing you might have
family problems you might have [ __ ]
career problems but just take a breath
for a second and just look outside look
at how green it is
or if you're in Detroit look at how gray
it is and just [ __ ] take a breath
into that [ __ ] car smog or beautiful
you know if you're in Montana it's
chilling and just think about you know
what I'm alive and yeah my back hurts
and yeah my nose is dry
and yeah there's people out there that
are trying to [ __ ] kill us and murder
us literally but you know what dude live
and be happy right trip actions
there's a reason half of business
travelers do not use their company's
chosen travel management platform I'll
say dude booking business travel is
still ridiculously outdated
time-consuming and costly now those
three things will bury you if you're
frustrated with your company's travel
management program or lack thereof you
need to look into trip actions they take
the pain out of corporate travel with a
complete solution that helps businesses
save and keeps employees happy and if
you don't have employer happy employees
you know I don't know what to tell you
the reason trip actions work so well is
that it's the first travel management
platform designed from the ground up
with the road warrior in mind it's easy
to book your company's business travel
from the app or desktop with 24/7
proactive support around the globe and
incentives for some for employees to
save on travel expenses companies large
and small save over 90% adoption and
save up see over 90% adoption and save
up to 34% on travel spend when they use
trip actions go to trip actions dot-com
/ Congrats complete a 30 minute demo
with a trip actions account executive
and you'll get $100 Amazon gift card but
it's this month only okay trip actions
dot-com / congrats for a free demo and
$100 Amazon gift gift card trip actions
calm / Congrats goat guys you like shoes
Yeezys Jordans off whites I do I've got
all of those three versions of things of
shoes if you're gonna buy sneakers for a
few hundred dollars with site which I do
all the time how can you be so sure
they're the real thing well I can tell
you how right now go calm if you're a
shoe guy like me
goat comm is the safest way to buy and
sell authentic sneakers online they're
the largest marketplace in the world for
authentic Yeezys Jordans and over
600,000 sneaker listings they've made
the whole process frictionless and
trustworthy they do this by only
accepting sellers with the best
reputation and by verifying all sneakers
to ensure their authenticity for buyers
every detail is inspected from the
stitching and color to the size and
weight Goat certifies that every pair of
sneakers of saw on their site matches
exact factory specifications you don't
want to do it if you're out there buying
shoes on like eBay trust me they they
send you fake stuff with over half a
million sneakers on the platform and 10
million users come on you're not gonna
find a better place verified 100%
authentic Steve's sneakers that's where
they are find the perfect 100% authentic
sneaker at go.com slash Congrats
that's goat dot-com / Congrats plus
you'll also be supporting our show but
you've got to go right now before the
sneakers you want are gone when you go
to goat comm / Congrats spelled Geo 80
comm / congrats congratulations is
brought to you by cash app America's
favorite alternative to balling up some
bills and throwing them at people you
owe money which is fun too but cash app
is way better people say now because I
have the vet the the desk that they
can't see my [ __ ] Heat I thought
about getting a shoe camp I got the
[ __ ] air max right there on I love
that color bro goddamn look at that a
[ __ ] love shoes bro I'm like a hooker
if I was a chick I'd suck dick for red
bottom straight up dude this unfollowing
thing is bonkers I can't believe I was
talking about it and then people are
sending me pictures for real of chicks
eating pizza like actually like I was
just making [ __ ] up they knew it was
happening but like to see it actually
happened the unfollowing man tagged him
up some guy drew some picture of me with
big tits with my face
the unfollowing dude it's real it's a
real thing um I don't even know which
way Quiznos is Wow dude
I left harder at that than I did all
probably the same as that remember I was
telling that [ __ ] tech TV video well
there's nothing like it it's a
one-of-a-kind and oh [ __ ] [ __ ] that just
walk right out that one too god I love
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude I love submit [ __ ]
anyway this guy gave me this [ __ ]
Ohio plate that says you could a lot of
people have been bringing me on the road
been bringing me a lot of really cool
stuff somebody brought brought me a pin
that's uh that says Newport News for
some reason I was in Newport News
because I always say every time I say
get tickets for Newport News for some
reason we sold that I sold that place
out and by we I mean me my open or had
nothing to do with it and and I sold it
out and Newport News for some reason
somebody made me a button that says
Newport News for some reason did shitman
me laughs and then somebody gave me a
towel that got the congratulations
[ __ ] logo on it it's sweet what
people give me and somebody gave me
another thing that says backing up the
Brinks truck I just cool and then
somebody gave me a shirt that says see
yet they read us which was [ __ ]
actually really a sweet gesture but the
shirt was why am I gonna wear a shirt
that says cioud they read us you know
what I mean and she was like look it as
the Blade Runner font and I was like
okay did I say so I don't remember half
the [ __ ] I say on this podcast by the
way unless the [ __ ] takes off like
obviously I know what a CUDA is because
I [ __ ] say that all the time did you
guys watch Game of Thrones I put that
video up on Instagram and it'll kind of
went viral there of me playing the
[ __ ] by the way okay it's a cello
guys hey stop Dorking it up okay I
played the vial I put the air violin
okay stop Dorking it up and telling me
it's actually this makes me laugh
because
it's not even a violin he's playing
wrong instrument it's a cello and those
stand upright so I'm not even trying to
I mean he can do what he wants obviously
get the humor in it but it's a cello so
if you wanted to be more accurate it can
be a cello sorry I do keep so yeah so I
didn't watch Game of Thrones because I'm
not caught up I'm on the [ __ ] fifth
season and uh you know I don't get these
memes where people are like nobody and
then it'll be like bran stark and he's
just standing there I don't get those
the whole nobody thing memes hey those
gotta go okay we're done with those
alright I get it and it is funny but
those got to go okay
nobody white chicks
but you know nobody black moms yeah we
get it
nobody Mexicans ebrill okay we got it
man nobody said [ __ ] and then the people
are the way they are we get it
[Music]
those memes memes ah [ __ ]
so what else do it I [ __ ] I don't
know I'm I [ __ ] anyway a game of
Thrones dude I can't believe how many
did I was at the Starbucks I went to a
Starbucks
I didn't know where I was but some girl
was like I was she's like what do you
want I was like iced americano by the
way I started getting the [ __ ] three
shots over ice it's way better dude
because they put too much water in the
[ __ ] americano sometimes you got to
[ __ ] have the three shots over ice
and then you [ __ ] the ice melts dude
[Laughter]
[Music]
dude do sometimes Starbucks tastes like
the back of a cow's mouth yes okay
do I order iced Americanos yes when I
get them too sometimes I put water and
did I put too much of it yes does it
make me stop getting it no do sometimes
on the ice melt too much and there's
even more water and the ratio is [ __ ]
up yes it is am I still gonna get it yes
but did I figure out something else to
do but that's better yes am I gonna do
it sometimes I'm gonna forget is it okay
yeah that's fun is gonna make my first
ready yes but I have to remember to get
the three shots over ice because the ice
melts and then it's an iced americano
it's also is it cheaper yes doesn't
matter
no don't have bags yes I don't know how
much I spent on coffee by the way all
year it's got to be [ __ ] 25 grand
[ __ ] but yeah so I mean if I what do I
spend I I probably spent about 6 bucks a
day on coffee a day that's ten dollars a
day
3650 a year I mean
[ __ ] one fire just gave me an
obviously for some reason like I'm a
piece of [ __ ] he did a calculator up
it's in 306 3650 I said three 2006 under
50 a year and he goes because I mean
obviously yeah Jesus Christ dude bro I'm
[ __ ] straight I've got some unpaid
some issues with me
just straight I mean obviously dude the
guy just [ __ ] hit me with like he's a
mom obviously I have [ __ ] to do
Jesus dude hello when somebody says
obviously or actually to you and you
know they hate you I'm actually no oh
wow that guy's so mad at his childhood
was [ __ ] rough you know so yeah so
3,000 I pay I for sure at least spend
$4,000 a year on coffee goddamn that's
[ __ ] too much dude I saw this chick
at the coffee bean with a fake ass I
keep I see more and more fake asses it's
unbelievable dude when when a girl has
fake tits that's one thing when the girl
has fake and a fake ass and walks into a
room everybody in the room should be
allowed to do this oh come on
and then she should just go like this
like it's a [ __ ] what do you call it
a sitcom and then it should freeze-frame
when I mean
girl's ass was so big it wasn't even it
wasn't even good it was like I wanted I
wanted everybody in it to just go come
on
all right are you [ __ ] know or for
[ __ ] sake when your ass is so fat that
your legs look it looks like a [ __ ]
toothpick with an olive on it hey hey
are you a martini how hey how are you a
[ __ ] martini
you see you go the fake ass you're just
like oh I must be James Bond that
because those aren't legs and an ass you
have toothpicks that have olives on the
side of them and I must be drinking a
martini and that's what James Bond
during literally the most convoluted
stupid [ __ ] of all time I would jump off
a building if I actually did that
goddamn I hate myself from doing that
dude ain't and tenant and tenant and
tenant and an in it you know how it
always is extra wanna piss me off
jintan tenant and tenant and tenant and
tenant star then lay in an intent and an
intent and an infant and an infant and
they it just one two yet an intense and
it [ __ ] makes me yeah you know what
dude I God theme songs with the [ __ ] I
never liked that theme song no offense
to whoever did it I'm sure it's great
and you're talented put that [ __ ]
either I you're talking about real theme
songs bro you're talking about the theme
songs dude
you know what's damn dude The Terminator
theme song are you kidding me bro
come on The Terminator theme song will
be awesome to have this on your iPod and
while you're [ __ ] an iPod shuffle put
this on like after D'Angelo and then you
should oh okay well wait hold on a
second I'm in it
[Music]
[ __ ] yeah dude yeah
bro have you ever been alive in the 80s
Scarface dude the [ __ ] song push it
to the limit is the most 80 [ __ ] of all
time
80 songs would be so [ __ ] specific
there's like this is what we're doing
there needs to be somebody that makes
this kind of music now nobody does it
come on into the [ __ ] words
here we go
[Music]
open up the limit so foreign
it starts with open ya open up that's
like a [ __ ] Italian [ __ ] in
America trying to talk about racecars
like well we go in you want to open up
the limit you want to go fast right you
want to open up the limit you cannot
have a [ __ ] 200 Mouse I don't know
how you do but miles per hour right
you have kilometres or however many you
open it up you open up the limit right
[Music]
so specific
so far reach that top but no you have to
learn how to keep it dude they [ __ ]
were like when the the Scarface
producers were like we want a [ __ ] a
song where it's like you know about a
guy who gets to the top and he's at the
top and then he's [ __ ] killing it but
then he wants to go further than the top
and how he wants to stay there and the
guys the guy was like we were gonna do
it no he was like well cuz he was
American so he's like I could probably
my Italian friends to write the lyrics
and they were like okay we'll see we'll
see what you do and then itchin and then
they and then it started coming and then
they were like
and they're like okay I don't know like
it's pretty 80s but I guess it is the
80s song and they're like ah okay well
I'll get up on Fisher talk a little time
but we did Thomas okay well you know
what that's very is a song over because
that's pretty much exactly all we told
him in the night
[Music]
I mean so much of this is just [ __ ]
like would be on a poster or a bumper
sticker like a bat out of hell like they
were like a battalion guys I go you have
to say bat out of hell right I was like
I guess so
crash the gates what going for the back
of the what going for the WHA going for
the back of the I don't know
[Music]
what's this a other thing you going for
the come on dude going for the bag of
beyond back of beyond Oh Oh going for
the back of beyond Wow
well you can't go further than that dude
beyond the back of it the back of the
furthest part
you haven't been to beyond you haven't
been you haven't gone to the beginning
of the beyond past that keep going the
[ __ ] back of beyond that's where
Scarface's that's so foreign
the back of beyond like that's the
cocking sort of got an Italian wrote
this [ __ ] and he was like there is no
words there's like a phrase or words in
Italian you know how like other
languages will be like well there is no
word for in English for it but in in
Spain it means basically beautiful
beautiful nature but you have to say
beautiful nature in America in English
but you call it la la la la it is the
Sun it is the sense of comfort you have
with a woman or a man in when you are in
love and we don't have that you don't
have that in America
but in Spain we call it
actively beyond
oh and now they're there dude now
they're there all of a sudden there
that's it there is no beyond they just
[ __ ] their whole song in the middle of
the song go into the back of beyond the
furthest part opened up the limit
[ __ ] at the top and keep it there
further than that blue and then [ __ ]
welcome to the limit okay so basically
we didn't realize that you can go this
far we thought there will be more we
even get way further but we don't need
[Music]
[Applause]
well he's still getting he's getting
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] satalia
is what is he the writer of course I
knew it was a foreign guy dude
you [ __ ] understand that when I
say some [ __ ] it's real this guy Italian
I told you dude I [ __ ] told you
Giorgio Mora Mora door is an Italian
Giorgio mordor wrote this [ __ ] song I
told you it was an Italian dude as the
founder of disco and an electronic music
trailblazer Giorgio Moroder door go up
has made his mark as an influential
Italian producer songwriter performer in
DJ I [ __ ] told you dude is that the
guy that did the [ __ ] [ __ ] with oh
yeah he's the father of disco yeah he
did with what do you call it if I were
an I'm Leland I who does that tough Punk
he did this [ __ ] with Daft Punk I think
even it's different
punk has a song where this guy's talking
over it though this guy found yeah
that's all yeah yeah so yeah
Giovanni Giorgi or Mordor dude I how
[ __ ] dude I don't even mean to toot
my own horn but how the [ __ ] good am i
for knowing that [ __ ] dude
and you and sometimes you listen to
these other podcasts dude I know [ __ ] if
I tell you a [ __ ] a tying I wrote
Scarface because he's saying open up the
limit that's what's up
I do that I go [ __ ] boom boom and I
go because I have flames on my [ __ ]
wrist so I [ __ ] like this [ __ ] on
goddamn fire dude that's what I do we do
that with my buddies I say some hot [ __ ]
and I go and they go and I light some
[ __ ] on fire and is it the dorkiest
thing I do not even close not even
[ __ ] close dude snap snap [ __ ]
sometimes I can't get it on fire Italian
the breads in the oven and breadsticks
Brown my mom so emotional she's crying
at the and everything good crimping
Remington dude [ __ ] that's cool
Giorgio Giovanni more Aldo Giovanni
George oh we got a [ __ ] we are [ __ ]
understand
anyway what else did where we at you
want to do the [ __ ] add or not the
adds to [ __ ] that missed connections
dude I loved I love you guys man thanks
for listening even though my [ __ ]
producer obviously has some pent up [ __ ]
about me because he said obviously to me
we're gonna do Los Angeles [ __ ]
Craigslist's because that's where it's
at dude la baby I rap la I'm not even 40
dude I'm young as [ __ ] bro have you seen
how young I am it's insane
I'm [ __ ] so young have you seen a
picture of me it's unbelievable it's
like I'm getting younger here we go Los
Angeles misconnections you love pancakes
okay
fat any girl want to go get some I hop
it's on me I want to go out more butt
hair to do it alone have to do it alone
I mean how do you miss that hate to do
it alone also planning on going to see
the national parks but that's something
else okay I mean yeah no [ __ ] man how
about a separate post or just you know
don't even post any of them if you would
like to join me on those adventure 2
then you are more than welcome
who wrote this Johnny George oh do not
contact with unsolicited services or
offers what you love what you love
pancakes why is it so aggressive and
then you love pancakes wow dude the
Internet has everything dude oh my god
this might be the best title ever so far
car BJ suction in sfv for a horny [ __ ]
by skilled bro my favorite part is
skilled bro hey man anyone dude like
it's a [ __ ] text to one person hey
man
anyone interested I'm cool DL dude gl
normal DD free chill guide down to suck
in your car if you need it I know the
good spots no worries
be cool normal DD free and ready to bust
all good do not contact me unsolicited
service offers dude ready to bust what
you're just a guy that wants to [ __ ]
get do something kinky bro ready to bust
hey man anyone interested I'm good so
many goddamn letters hey man anyone
interested I'm cool DL do GL normal DD
free with chill guy PSU ps4 b GG f th o
lost his mind there was some [ __ ]
place that was selling free letters and
he bought them all I got these extra
letters might as well put him in this
Facebook post car BJ suction sfv for a
horny [ __ ] by skilled bro and he wanders
a cool deal dude GL normal DD free this
guy's this guy's out to lunch bro just
so many letters don't contact this dude
with solicited services and offers
alright next one oh so romantic this one
we need to hold hands I walk along the
cliffs overlooking this ocean with
Walter my Bulldog a children's book he
he won't hold my hand will you wonderful
man needs a lady dude wow this guy
thought it was clever well my dog won't
hold my hand will you but by the way
your dog will hold your hand if you just
[ __ ] put your hand out do not contact
me with unsolicited services or offers
we need to hold hands a walk along the
cliffs overlooking the ocean with Walter
my bulldog
he won't hold my hand will you hey guy
Wow one with the Bulldogs thinking this
guy Bulldogs like our [ __ ] sake this
guy's so lonely young athletic baseball
player where is my young athletic
baseball player his name is Johnny and
he used to play ball in high school he
would drop by my place regularly for
some great head Jesus the way these just
[ __ ] open up the limit you know what
I mean like it's some of these I love
how they're so normal and then just open
up the limit with some great head you
know totally normal
where's my young athletic baseball
player his name is Johnny and used to
play ball in high school he would drop
by my place regularly regularly for some
great head you know do it
[ __ ] where is my young baseball
player his name is Johnny and he used to
play ball in high school he would drop
by my place regularly for some great
head
[Music]
good
yeah yeah
[Music]
Oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
this intercut baseball [ __ ] sliding
and then sucking
with the ball
[Music]
and then the [ __ ] reversed your [ __ ]
eyes I mean I shouldn't talk about this
but I did dude he said I was better than
his girlfriend if this is you hit me up
I miss you if not though this sounds
good to you hit me up oh I like he
doesn't even need the guy hey but listen
though if it's not you and this is
[ __ ] in your chilling and you just
feel like [ __ ] do it and you just
feel like straight more jerking [ __ ]
dude Oh a montage where a guy would be
playing baseball and dude no oh my god
bro that nothing would be funnier than
that if somebody please on the internet
make a montage of guys playing baseball
and also getting ahead duh yo you know
what that would be the funniest [ __ ]
thing but I got to the guy the the clips
of the guys getting ahead it has to be
really quick you can't dwell on it it
has to be like guys sliding running
hitting a ball [ __ ] fans like rah
and then just real quick like a like a
like that quick if this is you hit me up
I miss you if not though this sounds
like it sounds good to you hit me up you
must be under 30 years old no X no
exceptions wow wow dude so that's the
limit then the limit is [ __ ] one day
over 30
you must be under 30 year old no
exceptions d DF d DF athletic - good
shape and enjoy kicking back
kick him back young athletic built
kicking back straight married and
curious guys encouraged to respond do
not contact me unsolicited services or
offers Wow bro that might be my favorite
post of all time Jesus [ __ ] a guy
sliding into suck in second and then
getting sucked
that's so dude such a shipment last
night double tapered [ __ ] Wow well we
had a good one huh
[ __ ] that made me laugh what's up with
my [ __ ] okay so okay so Des Moines
Edmonton Victoria Chicago get your
tickets that's where the [ __ ] daddy's
coming dude we're gonna do some some
second and third shows there cuz the
popular demand so thank you download the
cash app for free on the App Store or
Google Play market we added shows by the
way in Tarrytown and Atlantic City as
well besides those other ones and
they're on sale presale now I don't know
what the code is I'll tweet it or
something like that but yeah Tarrytown
New Jersey and Italy or Tarrytown New
York is in New York New Jersey I don't
know Atlantic City up now so support the
show by buying merch we got those those
[ __ ] shirts my favorite one is the
unsolicited do not contact me with
unsolicited services and/or off our
services or offers that shirt is [ __ ]
fire dude I see all you two at the shows
with the merch when I'm on stage it's
[ __ ] dope that's how it really makes
me understand that that's this is a cult
and half a minutes to Mars they ain't
[ __ ] when it comes to cults so don't let
them get away with that [ __ ] when they
say that they're a cult they're not a
cult this is the cult we are the babies
subscribe to the YouTube channel please
rate and review our show subscribe to
the YouTube channel YouTube videos come
out our YouTube videos come out a day
after the audio and you could download
my my also my app and see it
before anyone else I'm also on a little
bit I'm doing a show
I did a show that just came out on
Friday I think on Netflix I'm in like 2
or 3 episodes
it's called huge in France it's GAD Elle
Malay my buddy did a has a Netflix TV
show enough likes TV show and I did
throw in a few episodes I play a version
of myself that's not actually myself but
it's it's fun it has to do a this [ __ ]
we shot some scenes at the Comedy Store
show like that anyway
have a good one guys and thank you and
remember don't be a super CUDA
[Music]